what if I told you last week I was a
bagger at Winn-Dixie like literally a
bagger and a cashier and I had the
uniform on I did that last week for an
hour in Liberty City while two people
got shot right across the street that's
literally what I did last week I'll
explain to you why I did that last
weekend combine it with a paradigm shift
and maybe something to ask yourself of
what's beneath you and by the way if you
get value from this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
so I'm interviewing Antonio Brown and
while we're sitting right here Antonio
Brown says you don't know what you're
talking about I'm from Liberty City I'm
like I grew up in Inglewood I mean my
dad is a 99 cent store in Inglewood so
you know you I grew up in LA but you
don't know what it's like I said in
Liberty City people can shout out I said
in Iran we get bombed on but that was a
choice to joined the army I said I was
born in Iran I didn't have a choice that
whole banter I don't know if you've seen
this so when he said that I came away
and I went and said I want to know what
Liberty City looks like never been there
before how about we do this what if we
go to Liberty City and I become a bagger
because I want to give myself a paradigm
shift to understand what that place
looks like rather than just talk about
or watch a video so we go to
Winn-Dixie's and I dress as a bagger and
me and cashier heaven and we're right
there going back and forth taking care
of customers and while customers are
coming I'm talking to everybody okay and
I'm talking to everybody what's your
story what do you do it's a teacher for
42 years about yourself single mother
what do you do I work for the city what
are you doing going back and forth and
all I'm doing at the end is listen do
you mind if I pay for your groceries
what yes can I go grab you some diapers
you're joking no and I paid for
everybody I think at the end of the day
we spend I don't know four or five
thousand dollars I don't know the number
but we paid for people for over an hour
the line got longer and longer and
longer within 30 minutes everybody was
calling there is this guy at aisle
number seven Winn-Dixie come by he's
paying for everybody right while I'm
doing this guess who said I want to go
with you my dad 80 years old is standing
to my right okay my dad was a cashier in
Inglewood 15 years in LA right next to
Great Western firm he was held up three
times three times he was held up you
know my dad that never gave the money he
took the Bible out I said dad you don't
do something like that that tells you
the character of my dad right so my dad
is standing there walking around he sees
this place in a completely different
lens he says I like their fruits very
good color healthy I like how I'm like
what are you talking about but that's
his lens because he ran a 99 cent store
do you know whole purpose of doing this
last week let's just have a paradigm
shift why for me to get an understanding
what's going on this Market what it's
looking like
if if I were to tell you right now if
you're somebody that's winning and you
had the best you make more money than
ever you drive a Lambo a Ferrari live in
a 10 million dollar house five million
dollar house you travel all over the
world and everybody around you is
winning you kind of need to pay a visit
to the other side you need to go to the
local community whatever you got a skid
row whatever City it is to find out what
it's really looking like to give you a
perspective of how lucky you are now
flip it if you're watching this 2021
2022 horrible year for you you went
through a divorce bad breakup you lost
it all 100 of your money was in Bitcoin
you were thinking it's going to go to
the moon and it did not you literally
lost your life savings in 2022 you're
down and out guess what you need to be
doing you need to go and sell the dream
to yourself go look at some 35 million
dollar house go to a Ferrari dealership
go to a community you want to live in go
to a private school and Shop to see what
it's like to send your kids to that
place you need to give yourself a
paradigm shift for you to start thinking
about what life could look like if you
decide to change because every once in a
while we all lose so going back I chose
to go to Winn-Dixie to have a paradigm
shift because I always want to be
connected to the people at every level
whether you make 10 bucks an hour I want
to be able to talk to you whether you're
white black Hispanic Asian middle
eastern millionaire billionaire broke
communist convict Democrat Republican
libertarian I don't care what you are I
want to be able to have a conversation
with you and learn from each other
because that tells you your winning
votes and that tells you having a
paradigm shift where everybody's got
something of value to give you and you
somehow someone can Inspire others to do
so something big with their lives so my
message to going into 2023 this whole
concept of Paradigm Shift isn't just for
you you got to create those appointments
I study for my series seven right next
to my grandmother's plot at Forest Lawn
her plot's right there I'm studying for
my series seven and every 30 minutes I
would walk around to read everyone's
names to see who I recognized or not and
said if you don't do something big with
your life you're going to be that person
born 1939 died in 1982 I don't know who
it is next person born 1946 died 2002 I
don't know who it is boom boom boom boom
boom looking at everybody that is my
Paradigm Shift you got to create some
Paradigm ships for yourself some for
your kids some for your spouse some for
your team to get people to think about
their dreams and ways they wouldn't
think without a paradigm shift having
said that if you want to go a little bit
deeper on this topic I gave a talk on
the difference between will versus Swant
tough to watch but if you've never seen
it click here to watch it you got value
from this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
foreign
[Music]